hi there reject nation I'm Greg Alba and
I'm John Humphrys we're gonna watch a
trailer for a new mobile game that is a
pretty popular PC game perfect world and
and our page and I've heard about this
game before the developing marketing
team asked us to check this out and we
were like sure why not let's go into it
it's always cool when you have
permission to check out a game tree I
liked their jingle
there are anomalies creatures that would
seek to do you to those of you who fear
the origins of these creatures are
shrouded in secrecy giant but according
to legend these creatures were once the
original inhabitants of this land
this is a drive from Chinese mythology
right yeah like they think
Homo sapiens for a time you needed peace
there came the discovery of heavens here
and the advent of war heavens
war waves of misses a nation life
[Music]
they're conscious 48 wait
over here this place I'm like pretty big
jump the oil smells Strasse cheese
became known as rays I kind of want to
play I ain't cool creator of this world
some would call me God but I am merely a
caretaker it was I am created
lest the we details of the ability to
fly I am gonna move the untain sounds
cacophonous the city for self-awareness
like radio waves were my gravest mistake
what were you going for I don't know why
did God for it Lucifer old but I cannot
to do so again you need our help as this
cell to collapse in the final of the sky
so concludes the age of the gods
[Music]
I leave custody of this world to the new
generation of heroes
[Music]
hey Ozzie required sacrifice unity Wi-Fi
or go to that question ask them girl
will get an answer to clear that level
text right here something it's awesome
whoa looks pretty cool doesn't I mean I
spent five bucks for the face app so for
399 oh yeah of course you sit here you
complaining how free is this gonna be
after I the $5 you got a lot out of that
$5.00 yeah that looks really cool man it
looks really cool different creatures in
the different you know mythological I'm
not very well versed in Eastern
mythology by any stretch but just the
imagery don't act humble John you know
much about Eastern mythology an X letter
now let me claim deities never lets them
sell shine man you know you know I love
the look of the raves and the different
worlds and stuff this looks unique
especially in this realm because at
least for us we've seen a lot of the
stuff that's based on like Norse
mythology and things that are more
Western or more in cheats and stuff like
that wipe so it's cool to go to a
different side of mythology ever a phone
game for a mobile app if this truly does
represent what you'll be able to do in
the game or at least with some of the
cutscenes and stuff will look like it
seems like a pretty ambitious task to
bring this to the phone like I said have
heard of the PC version of this and that
was pretty freakin popular I think for a
lot of people that was like one of the
first MMORPG games this under 100 yeah
and to be able to do all this I believe
there is a capacity into definitely and
all of that an app I wasn't sure when we
were looking at like cutscenes sometimes
or when we were looking at actual
gameplay but his MMORPGs you know they
usually look like a cutscene yeah
because of the kind of gameplay it is
part of the point is the experience of
it where you take your story well that
was the other thing as this story
actually looks really cool I feel like a
lot of time we get something that's like
a very basic setup with some cool movie
looking footage and then a very generic
game but what I love it about the
trailers they establish a very very
specific world we have a very specific
purpose and mission that we have to
fulfill that will encompass even further
exploration this seems a lot bigger than
I expected it to actually be or a mobile
game yeah definitely especially in like
the worlds it seems like you're gonna
spend a good time going to and jumping
between and I hope the guy who is
essentially God shows like it's gonna be
like ready player one or something he's
gonna show up at the end once you've
brought the world back to perfection and
he's gonna present you with some kind of
special Faberge egg or something I'm
excited for that one Humphrey oh yeah
it's gonna be great
one thing that I also intrigues me about
this like mic milady milady she's been
playing got a war just beat it and so
like you're bringing it up with the kind
of mythology that explores there it put
it out a path to like research the
actual mythology and to see how accurate
God award is and I'm wondering how
accurate the Chinese mythology here is
as well this way I can participate in
conversations with my chinese-american
friends and then be like how do you not
know about this
you're Chinese yeah Phil yeah don't
disrespect film and a great guy he's got
a lot of knowledge Bill's got a sense a
lot of things it is always cool to even
if it's not on or isn't accurate to get
some insight into yeah it is a nice day
no Thor Loki or a thing until I saw the
MCU that is
Beowulf's an epic poem it's not just a
robert zemeckis tech tutorial this I
feel like we'll probably be able to
gather a lot of knowledge yeah yeah or
at least you know set us on the path
while having a rip snortin good time
riding through fantasy lands on giant
swords and stuff I'm sure I mean we
could probably just look at the PC game
for details but you have the humans
the elves a wing and elves and then what
is the third the wraiths know the bad
guys yeah the untamed gosh I thought you
knew he's terminology yeah that's what I
said at the beginning is there an expert
totally you get a probably hover between
who you want to play as right I met it
well full human never gonna touch the
other two hey how would I do that
I don't relate I'm gonna spend the whole
game trying to find ways of crossing
them of like hybridizing every cast of
character well this dude has like a lion
head or something I know a tiger head
yeah why wouldn't you want to be that
come on I want to be that guy in real
life oh don't be that guy in real life I
think that would make things a little
difficult for you perhaps unless we live
in a Bojack horseman world where that's
normal
well I think it's really just about how
you carry yourself Jeff it's all about
how you say it it's not about what you
say it's how you look not how you feel
all right well the team behind perfect
world thank you for allowing us check
this out this sounds really exciting
appreciate you guys emailing us yeah
John so what can the the people who
watch this video do oh you want to know
what they can do well you can go down to
that description bottle is here you can
vote watch the democratic debate hit the
like button but most important of all
you can go down to the description box
and get that pre-registration link so
you can jump in for the second the game
goes live mmm you know it's been a while
since there's been a perfect world game
out there and it's gonna come into the
new age I've been allotted a man for
this I hear sound they heard the people
awesome possum lady blossom hit up that
link yeah subscribe
see you guys
you